be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
I don't understand you wanted brothers I
really no I do not understand your
warner brothers i do not understand how
you can do so bad with the Justice
League and then do so spectacular with
the Joker by the way this video is gonna
have spoilers The Joker film is amazing
it is amazing it is it's everything I
thought it would be it's everything I
wanted it to be right I didn't want it
to be a movie where it was like a like a
take on like Mark Hamill's Joker from
from Batman the Animated Series I didn't
want it to be a movie where it was
trying to recapture the magic of Heath
Ledger's Joker from The Dark Knight
Returns I didn't want it to be any of
that I wanted it to be a standalone film
I wanted to be a movie that could stand
on its own and just be amazing and it
was it really was I did not think
Joaquin Phoenix could actually play a
good Joker and then he does like he
plays this amazing Joker over the course
of the film and it's it's it's fantastic
to watch his character just kind of like
progress and grow and change and here's
the craziest thing about it here's the
craziest thing about it you feel for the
gummy right like you look at this guy's
story and you're like this guy's got
like the crappiest life I mean certainly
not the worst life a person could have
but definitely not the best like the guy
like the guy's life is just like a
walking sad miserable story right like
you know the in The Killing Joke the
idea behind the Joker becoming the Joker
was it all it takes is one bad day and
this guy all it takes is one bad life
and then he ends up becoming the Joker
it was it was it was incredible okay so
so so if you want the non spoilery
version of this review it's simple go
see it right if you go into it expecting
Heath Ledger's Batman or hey I'm sorry
Heath Ledger's Joker you're gonna be
disappointed that's not what you get and
and you shouldn't get that but
that's not what should be shot for here
you shouldn't be trying to duplicate
what somebody else did just try to like
you know do your own and that's that's
really what what the Joker movies doing
here um if you're going in here
expecting a somewhat of like an origin
and deconstruction of the Joker then
that's what you get and it's it's it's
really really good just go into it not
expecting a absolute comic book origin
of the Joker really there really isn't
one I mean The Killing Joke is as good
as you get but even The Killing Joke
story Alan Moore's like it's not
necessarily his own origin like it's not
even it's not even really accurate
people just assume that it's accurate
because it's the closest thing we have
to an origin right it's the one that the
DC kind of points to but they will until
somebody else comes along it sounds like
this is the definitive version of the
Joker but on the last right so anybody
who tells you that The Killing Joke is
the absolute origin of the Joker don't
believe them because in the story itself
I don't even say that it's the absolute
origin having said that getting into
like the spoilery stuff right like
spoiling the movie this film was it was
it was incredible right so so first
things first you're introduced to the
guy his name is Arthur Fleck right and
and you know a fleck unimportant Neal a
flick um not to say it's a flick is is
an unimportant concept basically at
least in terms of him being an
unimportant guy um you're not gonna see
any of the characters leave familiar
with from DC Comics right so you're not
gonna see Jim Gordon you're not gonna
see Harvey Bullock and indeed it makes
sense because the way this movie plays
out um this guy is it looks like he's
probably in like like more I made a good
point looks like he's in his late 30s
early 40s and then of course you're
gonna see the Wayne family you're gonna
see Thomas Wayne you're gonna see Martha
Wayne you're gonna see Bruce Wayne and
and basically you know this guy is amiss
for use at the time the Bruce Wayne is a
little kid it's essentially the idea the
cool thing about this is that it does
lead into a movement it is political in
terms of how it's done right it is it is
it is pretty political um its political
in somewhat of a subtle way but not even
a really subtle way right like though
the whole idea is that it focuses on the
rise of this guy becoming the children
and not insofar that he's just like I
want to conquer the world and I'm just a
terrible person I want to do bad things
it's really more of the fact that he's
just he starts to kind of lose his mind
as the movie goes on is we
the idea behind he kind of gets gets fed
up there's a few things that he does
there's one instance where um these guys
these guys were jerks indicted jerks to
death these guys were jerks in in a
subway and he basically freaked out and
you know when when they were you know
drunken and you know harassing this one
chick she ends up getting up and leaving
when he starts laughing uncontrollably
because the idea behind his laughter
there's a couple scenes where you see
that like where he's walking down a
hallway and buttoning up his shirt you
saw that in the trailer it's because he
has a laugh that he can't control and so
because of that there's the huge base
that starts laughing on the subway train
and these guys freak out and and they're
like what well you know what's so funny
and then he pulls a gun and shoots him
now how he gets the gun I'm gonna go
into that but he pulls a gun and shoots
something from there it begins a
downward spiral and to him basically
accepting the fact that for the most
part his life is a joke like he doesn't
really matter nobody cares you know and
anything like that that his life is a
joke he goes in this downward spiral and
ultimately ends up turning into the
Joker the funny thing about this is that
aside from that and maybe one or two
other instances he does really kill
anybody that's kind of the funny thing
like like it's really more focusing on
the nature of his security right I mean
he kills those three guys he kills
another guy and then he kills he kills
uh he kills another guy he kills Eagles
well-used you directly see him kill
probably have five people over the
course of the movie uh one of them is is
is really cool it's really interesting
the way it goes down why because it
progresses the story in a new way but
having said that there are a lot of
political tones here by there's there's
the tone of you know people who feel
disenfranchised like people who feel
like they're exceedingly poor and their
life is really probably kind of the
wealth gap that you see going on right
now right look 99% versus the 1%
you know the rich keep getting richer
and the poor keep getting poorer it
really it really seems to focus on the
notion of things being being rough for a
lot of people um and and it's actually
done exceedingly well because I sort of
answers the question what happens when
one people get fed up with being walked
on all the time and to somebody leads
them into a place where they feel like
they can act and they can basically make
their point known without fear of
repercussions basically there's nobody
really knowing who they are it really
answers that question exceedingly well
so job really becomes more of like a
martyr than anything I'm not really
maybe becomes more of a of a symbol than
anything else
yeah the movie does take place in Gotham
City that is true you do have you have
Thomas Wayne you have Mark Twain you
have Bruce Wayne the story like the the
whole history between Thomas Wayne and
Arthur Fleck is actually really really
cool um it is it's really really awesome
and then one of the things you actually
end up learning here is that Arthur
Fleck is not his name it's not the name
of the Joker you never find out what his
name is
which really leaves it open for him
actually being a man by the name of Jack
Napier which is really for the most part
again pointing to the Killing Joke the
the identity that most fans just assume
is the real name of the Joker and so um
you know it's cool like it the movie is
the movies fantastic the movie is is
okay the movies mind-blowing um it's
it's it's the best movie that that
Warner Brothers has made to date it's
it's the best movie that one of us at
least in terms of a comic book movie not
not in general it's not the best movie
they had ever made of all time but in
terms of in terms of a comic book
adaptation it's the best movie they made
today and in reality I think they're
gonna uh sure in a nuclear status quo I
think between venom and between the
Joker between these two guys they're
gonna bring in a new status quo the new
paradigm shift of comic book movies is
gonna be focusing on the Joker are
focusing on the villains because it's
the one thing that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has failed to do so far is they
failed to capitalize on right they've
always killed their villains and they
never made their villains very
intriguing they never really focus on
the villains existed to serve the
narrative of what makes a superhero a
superhero and that's it but then I think
the beauty behind of what it is that
that Warner Brothers is hopefully going
to figure out and what it is is so is
hopefully gonna figure out between the
these two villain films more or less
that they've made is that a lot of times
the villains are more intriguing than
the superheroes but like that like like
like the Joker I think is more
interesting than Batman magneto I think
is more interesting than like all the
x-men uh you know venom I think is in a
lot of ways more interesting than Peter
Parker especially when you look at the
history the symbiote different things
like that but I digress here um the
villains are in a lot of ways more
interesting than the superheroes not all
of them but a lot of them are and I feel
like that's gonna be the new shift I
think people are gonna sit down and say
okay you know if mama wants to focus on
all the all the superhero stuff we'll
focus on the Philips like we'll build up
a rogue's gallery like will build up
stories about the villains having said
that the movie does work in a way to
where well one of others did come out
and say it's not in continuity it might
be a game they're playing in cases like
bombs completely and continuity so does
it really matter you know whether it
does good or bad we can kind of shuffle
it under the rug and then we can bring a
joker into them - the new Batman movie
similar on one it's it's it's it's
written where it could be that way but
then it's also written to where it could
be in continuity it could go either way
I prefer that it be in continuity to be
honest with you guys the way this is the
way this Joker is political portrayed
about Joaquin Phoenix I prefer that it
be in continuity um it is it's a it's
it's just it's a fantastic film right
it's an amazing film does it feel like a
comic book movie no and I think that's
what makes it good I think that's what
makes it so awesome is is the DC hasn't
quite yet nailed the formula I'm sorry
not DC Warner Brothers and I quite yet
nailed the formula for how to make a
comic book movie that feels kinda like a
comic book movie but isn't a comic book
movie they don't really nailed that what
they have nailed here is the ability to
make a movie that does feels nothing
like a comic book movie but happens to
have a comic book character in it
they've nailed that perfectly and while
that may sound like a bad thing it's not
because what you get is a carrot is a
villain that you know and love you get
an origin story for this villain
basically and a really really intriguing
one as well it's full of twists and
turns and all that kind of stuff but at
the same time it doesn't feel like a
like a like a comeback movie it doesn't
feel like a Marvel Cinematic Universe
movie it feels like like a tried and
true you know non kind of book movie
this is amazing like I could see this
thing possibly getting an Oscar or being
nominated for an Oscar LT will but you
know it's it has that kind of feel to it
like a non comic book movie that happens
a feature kind of like Hitler I don't
that makes any sense to us um but yeah
it's it's an incredible film it's
definitely an incredible film I would
highly suggest that you go check it out
it's it's it's great it is kind of a
one-off but so it's not one of these
things where I would go and see it again
not because I thought the movie was bad
but because there was nothing so
captivating that were driving
the theaters a second ton but but you
guys need to go see it like you guys
have to go watch this movie it is it's
one of the few times that you've
probably heard me say Wonder Brothers
has made an amazing movie that features
a comic book character if this is the
future the kind of movies are gonna make
but like if this is because it's not
even about the the the the tone of the
film units to a degree but the tone of
the Joker was captured perfectly in the
tone of the film if they can do that in
future movies and they can make a movie
about it come up with character and
capture the tone of that coming of a
character in that movie while making it
feel like you're not watching a coming
of movie or watching like a non comic
book film I think they're gonna smash
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I think
you go forward with this and if they can
make a Batman movie that that fits the
tone of Batman and if they can make a
Superman movie that fits the tone of
Superman and Wonder Woman and the Green
Lantern and and Shazam did it great
she's had a great job of that if they
can if they can make movies like that
that fit the tone of the character as
opposed to finding the talent of the
director which is what you saw with with
Aquaman it fit the tone of the director
it did not fit the tone of the character
um if you go forward with movies that do
that that fit the tone to the character
I think that I think I think that I
think DC I think Wonder brothers could
smash the Marvel Cinematic Universe in a
lot of ways especially if they do what
the MCU is not doing which is focusing
on villains they include the heroes but
then also give us villains movies
fantastic you guys have to go see it
without thing so guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end and uh yeah I will
catch you all later
[Music]